Reactome is a free open source, curated, and
peer-reviewed knowledgebase of biomolecular
pathways.
This tool enables users to browse and perform
pathway analysis, and overlay their own data
on top of the diagrams.
The pathway browser consists of several components.
A species selector and other options are placed
on the top.
The event hierarchy is on the left.
The details panel is at the bottom and it
includes six tabs: description, molecules,
structures, expression, analysis, and downloads.
Finally, the viewport at the center of the
screen displays the pathways overview and
the diagram viewer.
The event hierarchy can be used to browse
through pathways and reactions.
All components in the browser are tightly
connected and respond to each other's actions
such as hovering over items or their selection.
The search feature in the pathway overview
can be used to find a specific pathway by
its name.
Clicking on one of the search results select
the item and causes an update of every component
of the viewer.
Clicking on the diagram icon opens the diagram
view.
When the diagram opens the location of sub
pathways are highlighted by shaded boxes.
Selecting the fireworks like icon brings the
pathway overview back to the viewport.
Selecting a reaction on the event hierarchy
opens the containing pathway and zooms in
to focus on the selected reaction.
Transitions between the overview and pathway
diagrams are animated.
Once an item is selected, detailed information
is available in the different tabs of the
details panel.
• The description tab shows curated information
stored in the reactome database.
• The molecules tab provides information
about the participating molecules.
• The structures tab shows structural information
from third-party resources.
Querying protein databank for proteins, ChEBI
for chemicals, and Rhea for reactions.
• The expression tab retrieves data from
the expression Atlas across a standard set
of tissues and organs.
• The Downloads tab shows buttons to download
the pathway in several formats for reuse or
reference.
The user can control the level of information
by zooming in and out.
Initially all trivial molecules are hidden
and shaded boxes highlight the locations of
sub pathways.
As the view zooms in, the trivial molecules
progressively appear while the shaded boxes
fade out.
As zooming continues, stoichiometry and PTMs
are shown.
When fully zoomed, in the shapes representing
proteins and chemicals reveal their molecular
structures and associated information.
When the mouse pointer is hovered over an
entity, a small triangle appears inside it.
Clicking the triangle or right-clicking on
the entity itself opens a context dialog with
more information such as its participating
molecules and other pathways where this entity
occurs.
Three buttons at the top right corner control
toggling for names to identifies.
Pinning the contacts dialog box to the view
or closing it.
The search feature in the diagram viewer can
be used to find entities events or interactors
within the displayed pathway.
Selecting a result in the search makes the
view smoothly transition to the area of interest.
Different color profiles can be selected in
order to change the appearance of the displayed
diagram.
Clicking on the red circle at the top-right
corner of an entity reveals its interactors
from the intact database in a radial layout.
More information can be found in the interactors
tab in the context dialog.
When fully zoomed in, the interactor shapes
reveal their molecular structures and associated
information.
Interactors can be filtered by confidence
score using the slider.
Different color profiles can be selected to
change the appearance of the displayed interactors.
More interactive resources can be selected
in the settings panel to facilitate easy navigating
between resources.
The revealed interactors layout is remembered
when a source is reselected.
The pathway browser enables users to import
an overlay and their own data as a custom
resource.
The inline documentation provides more information
about the custom resources.
The different ways of submitting the data
and the supported formats.
Once uploaded custom resources will remain
available for at least seven days.
This period of time is automatically extended
by frequent usage.
The last part of this introductory video is
about the analysis of user data.
Different kinds of data can be submitted via
the analysis submission interface.
There are three steps to the analysis submission
process.
Selection of the data to be analyzed, setting
the available options, and performing the
analysis.
Inline documentation is also available.
Results are displayed in the analysis tab
of the details panel and overlaid on the pathways
overview providing a bird's-eye view to facilitate
browsing.
The color of the overlay indicates the significance
of the pathway match.
When a pathway is selected, a marker indicates
its expression level on the right side of
the scale.
Hovering the mouse pointer over another pathway
places a marker on the left side of the expression
scale, allowing comparison.
Analysis results overlaid on to pathway diagrams,
enable navigation through a series of submitted
expression samples such as a time series.
In pathway diagrams entities that were represented
in the submitted dataset are colored.
Granularity of the overlay increases with
the level of zoom.
When zoomed in, complexes and sets are overlaid
with colored strips to indicate the expression
of their participating molecules.
When interactors have been included in the
analysis, if an interactive an entity has
been hit by the sample, a ribbon is shown
on the entity.
When the interactors are revealed, those that
were hit are colored on the View and in the
context dialog.
Different analysis color profiles can be selected
to change the appearance of the results overlay.
The pathway browser provides a variety of
options to export the analysis results as
an image or a file.